This lecture is about the feedback in
the vector space model.
In this lecture we continue talking
about feedback in text retrieval.
Particularly, we're going to talk about
feedback in the vector space model.
As we have discussed before, in the
case of feedback.
The task of a Text Retrieval system is
to learn from examples to improve
retrieval accuracy.
We will have positive examples.
Those are the documents that are
assumed to be relevant or judgement be
relevant.
Or the document that are viewed by
users.
We also have negative examples.
Those are documents known in non-relevant, and
they can also be the document that
escaped by users.
The general method in the vector space
model for feedback.
Is to modify our query vector and we
want to place the query vector in a
better position to make the accurate.
And what does that mean exactly?
If we think about the query vector,
that would mean we have to do something
to the vector elements.
And in general, that would mean we
might add new terms.
We might adjust weights of all terms or
assign weights to new terms.
And as a result, in general the query
will have more terms, so we often call
this query expansion.
The most effective method in the vector
space model for feedback is called
Walker feedback, which was after he
proposed at several decades ago.
So the idea is quite simple.
We illustrate this idea by using a 2
dimensional display of all the
documents in the collection and also
the query vector.
So now we can see the query vector is
here in the center.
And these are all the documents.
So when we use the query vector and use a
similarity function to find the most
similar documents, we are basically
drawing a circle here and then.
These documents would be basically the
top ranked of the documents.
And these pluses are relevant
documents.
And these are relevant documents.
For example is relevant, etc.
And then these minuses are negative
documents like this.
So our goal here is trying to move this
query vector to some position to
improve the retrieval accuracy.
By looking at this diagram.
What do you think?
Where should we move the query of after
so that we can improve the retrieval
accuracy?
Intuitively, where do you want to move
the query vector?
Now, if you want to think more, you can
pause the video.
Now, if you think about this picture,
you can realize that in order to work
well in this case you want to query
about that to be as close to the
positive vectors as possible.
That means ideally you want to place
the query vector somewhere here, or you
want to move the query vector closer to
this point.
Now, So what exactly is this point?
Well, If you want these relevant documents to
be ranked on the top, you want this to
be in the center of all these relevant
documents, right?
Because then if you draw a circle
around this one, you get all these
relevant documents.
So that means we can move the query
vector towards the centroid of all the
relevant locking vectors.
And this is basically the idea of Rocchio
you.
Of course you can consider the centroid
of negative documents, and we want to
move away from the negative documents.
Not geometrically, we're talking about
the movie vector closer to some other
bath and away from other vectors.
Algebraically, it just means we have
this formula.
Here you can see this is original query
vector.
And, this average basically is the
centroid vector of relevant documents.
When we take the average of these
vectors, then we are computing the
centroid of these vectors and similarly
this is the average non relevant
document vectors.
So it's essentially of non relevant
documents and we have these three
parameters here of our alpha beta and gamma
they're controlling the amount of
movement.
When we add these two vectors together,
we are moving the query
closer to the centroid.
I said add them together when we
subtract this part.
We kind of move the query vector away
from that
Central.
So this is the main idea of Rocchio
feedback and after we have done this we
will get a new query vector which can
be used to store documents.
This newer query vector will then
reflect the move of this original query
vector toward this relevant centroid
vector and away from the non relevant
centroid vector.
OK, so let's take a look at the
example.
This is the example that we have seen
earlier, only that I give the display
of the actual documents.
I only showed the vector representation
of these documents.
We have 5 documents here.
And we have.
Two relevant the documents here.
Right?
They are displayed in red and these are
the term vectors and I have just
assumed some TF IDF weights. A  lot of
terms.
We have zero weights of course and
these are negative documents.
There are two here.
There was another one here.
Now in this Rocchio method we first
compute the centroid of each category I
so let's see.
Look at the centroid vectors of the
positive documents.
What we simply just, so it's very easy
to see.
We just add this with this one.
The corresponding element, and that's
down here and take the average and then
we will know added the corresponding
elements and then just take the average
right?
So we do this for all these.
In the end what we have is this one.
This is the average vector of these
two.
So it's a centroid of this two.
That's also look at the centroid of the
negative documents.
This is basically the same. we are gonna
take the average of three elements.
And these are the corresponding
elements in the three vectors, and so
on so forth.
So in the end we have this one.
Now in the Rocchio Feedback Method,
we're going to combine all these with
the original query vector, which is
this.
So now, let's see how we combine them
together.
That's basically this.
I saw we have a parameter alpha
controlling the original period
weight, that's one, and then we have
beta to control the influence of the
positive centroid weight that's
1.5 that comes from here.
Alright, so this.
Goes here.
And we also have this negative
weight here, controlled by Gamma here and
this weight that has come.
From of course the negative centroid here.
And we do exactly the same for other
terms.
Each is for one term.
And this is our new of vector.
And we're going to use this new query
vector.
This one to rent the documents.
You can imagine what would happen right
because of the movement that this one
would match these red documents much
better because we move this vector
closer to them and it's going to
penalize these black documents in these
non relevant documents.
So this is precisely what we want from
feedback.
Now, of course, if we apply this method
in practice.
We will see one potential problem.
And that is the original query has only
four terms that are.
non-zero
But after we do query expansion, you
can imagine it would have many terms
that would have nonzero weights.
So the calculation would have to
involve more terms.
In practice, we often truncate this
vector, and only retain the terms with
highest weights.
So let's talk about how we use this
method in practice.
I just mentioned that we often
truncated adapter and see the only a
small number of words that have highest
weights in the centroid vector. This is
for efficiency concern.
I also say that here that negative
examples or non relevant examples tend
not to be very useful, especially
compared with positive examples.
Now you can think about why.
One reason is because negative
documents tend to distract the query in
all directions.
So when you take the average it doesn't
really tell you where exactly should be
moving too.
Where is positive documents tend to be
clustered together and they will point
you to a consistent direction.
So that also means sometimes we don't
have to use those negative examples.
But note that in some cases in
difficult queries where most top ranking
results are negative, negative feedback
factor is very useful.
Another thing is to avoid overfitting.
That means we have to keep relatively
high weight on original query terms.
Why? Because
The sample that we see in feedback is a
relatively small sample.
We don't want to overly trust the
small sample.
An the original query terms are still
very important.
Those terms of typing by the user and
the user has decided that those terms
are most important.
So in order to prevent us from
overfitting or drifting the topic with
preventing topic drifting due to bias
toward the feedback examples, we
generally would have to keep a pretty
high weight on the original terms.
It's always safe to do that.
And this is especially true for pseudo
relevance feedback.
Now this method can be used for both
relevance feedback and pseudo relevance
feedback.
In the case of pseudo feedback up, the
parameter beta should be set to a
smaller value because the relevant
examples are assumed to be relevant.
They are not as reliable as the
relevance feedback.
In the case of relevance feedback, we
obviously could use a larger value, so
those parameters they have to be set in
imparallelly.
And the root Rocchio.
method is usually robust.
and effective.
It's still very popular method of all
feedback.